REPEATEDLY AND SYSTEMATICALLY
VIOLATES HUMAN RIGHTS DOES NOT
DESERVE A DIME.
>> Sean: I THINK WE LEARNED
THAT CONGRESSWOMAN OCASIO-CORTEZ
IS ALSO FACING A SERIOUS
CHALLENGE IN NEW YORK'S 14TH
DISTRICT, BECAUSE RISING G.O.P.
STAR SHAREE MURRAY IS AN
IMMIGRANT AND ENTREPRENEUR,
ANNOUNCING CANDIDACY TODAY.
THIS IS HER FIRST INTERVIEW.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
WE APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US.
THANK YOU.
>> IT IS A PLEASURE TO BE WITH
YOU THIS EVENING, SEAN.
>> Sean: I JUST HEARD WHAT SHE
SAID, WE HAVE 12 YEARS, IT DOES
NOT MATTER HOW WE ARE GOING TO
PAY FOR IT.
12 YEARS LEFT WE SHOULD NOT BE
EATING HAMBURGERS FOR BREAKFAST,
LUNCH, DINNER.
I DON'T KNOW ANYONE THAT DOES
THAT.
IN THE CONCENTRATION CAMP,
ET CETERA COMMENT, AND
EVERYTHING THAT YOU JUST HEARD,
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> WELL, IT IS DISGUSTING.
THE NARRATIVE ON THE NATIONAL
LEVEL NEEDS TO BE DIALED BACK.
AND THAT IS WHY I AM IN THE RACE
PRAYED I WOULD LIKE TO REPRESENT
THE CONSTITUENTS IN QUEENS AND
THE BRONX.
AND WE SEE AOC AS FROM THE TIME
SHE HAS BEEN ELECTED, SHE PUT
OUT A POLICY LIKE THE JOB
KILLING GREEN NEW DEAL.
SHE'D THEN WENT ON TO KILL THE
AMAZON DEAL IN NEW YORK, WHICH
WOULD HAVE PUT SOME 25,000 JOBS
IN QUEENS.
AND SO THESE ARE SOME OF THE
REASONS ALONG WITH KITCHEN TABLE
ISSUES THAT I DO BELIEVE THAT
AOC HAS NEGLECTED IN HER
LIMELIGHT TO FOCUS ON IN THE
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT.
SPIN ON THOSE 25,000 JOBS IN THE
DISTRICT YOU ARE RUNNING AGAINST
HER, AVERAGE PAY OF 150 GRAND.
I DID THINK THE GOVERNOR AND THE
MAYOR OF NEW YORK WERE CRAZY IN
THEIR GIVEAWAYS.
IT IS UNFAIR TO GIVE BENEFITS TO
ONE COMPANY AND NOT ANOTHER
COMPANY.
THAT IS A DIFFERENT STORY.
BUT SAYING DO WE HAVE TO
QUESTION HAVING KIDS, THEY DID
SAY THOUGH GREEN NEW DEAL
WHETHER YOU ARE WILLING OR
UNWILLING TO WORK, BASICALLY
EVERYTHING IS FOR FREE.
NO MORE OIL OR GAS IN TEN YEARS.
IF WE ONLY HAVE 12 YEARS LEFT
AND WE HAVE TO DO THIS ALL IN
TEN YEARS, WHY DON'T WE JUST
PARTY THE NEXT 12 YEARS AND IT
IS OVER ANYWAY?
>> WELL, SEAN, YOU HAVE SOME
POINTS THERE.
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE TO
START TALKING ABOUT THE ISSUES
THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO THE
CONSTITUENTS OF THE 14TH
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT IN QUEENS
AND THE BRONX.
WITH THE STRUCTURE THAT IS
IMPORTANT TO THE CONSTITUENTS.
THE SUBWAY SYSTEM IS CRUMBLING
PRAYED OUR ROADS ARE IN
DESPERATE NEED OF REPAIR, ALSO,
SEAN, OUR EDIFICATION.
WE NEED TO REALLY TALK OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM WITH THE
DIVERSITY IN NEW YORK, THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
WE REALLY NEED TO START TALKING
ABOUT POLICY THAT IS GOING TO
CONNECT WITH THE EVERYDAY
AMERICAN.
SHE MENTIONS NO CHILDREN OR
KIDS.
I AM A MOM.
>> Sean: HOW WOULD YOU
DESCRIBE YOURSELF POLITICALLY?
AND HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE TWO PLUS
YEARS, TWO AND A HALF YEARS THAT
HE HAS BEEN IN OFFICE?
>> I AM MIGRATED HERE FROM
JAMAICA, I KNOW FIRSTHAND WHAT
IT IS NOT JUST TO BE AN
IMMIGRANT, BUT TO GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS, RIGHT, AND WHAT DO I
THINK ABOUT WHAT THE PRESIDENT
IS DOING?
I THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
DELIVERING ON HIS PROMISES WHEN
HE GOT ELECTED.
>> Sean: YEAH, WELL, YOU ARE
ANNOUNCING YOUR CANDIDACY, AND
WE WILL WATCH THIS VERY CLOSELY.
I HAVE NOTICED THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN THE DISTRICT WITH
25,000 JOBS, $150,000 ON
AVERAGE, SHE LET THAT GO.
I DON'T THINK THERE WAS A GOOD
MOVE.
>> I WANT TO GET ALL OF YOUR
VIEWERS TO GO TO MY WEBSITE SO
THAT THEY CAN LOOK ON IT A
LITTLE BIT MORE.
SCHERIE MURRAY.COM.
FOLLOW ME ON TWITTER.
IT HAS BEEN OVERWHELMING AND A
BLESSING WITH WHAT I HAVE
RECEIVED SO FAR, THE ENTHUSIASM,
THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOUR VIEWERS
AND EVERYONE OUT THERE THAT HAS